mathieu vous qui connaissez une physique
vous êtes très fort enfin si vous le
trouvez vous ah non vraiment c'est déjà
non mais n'est pas du tout pas du tout à
ses mails et chats
benjamin les meufs le kif et j'ai eu
encore la confirmation tout à l'heure
j'ai prendre dossier pour vous écouter
lens après mon frère fu te démerdes chez
moi ça m'arrange sage et foutent en
l'air cette bande a donné ça comme
obliger cabossé il aima stocks et buriné
il a beaucoup de charme avant une
élection de shakespeare mais charme sais
pas si c'est mieux mais un charme c'est
ce qu'on dit des gens qui ont pas de
physique ce domaine est vendu ça non
mais il a une belle gueule il a une
gueule mais monsieur machin battue ouais
tu n'es ni charme 1,10 physique
oh non
ce qui se dit mais qui ces scénarios
communs comme un jeune nantais vieux
déjà et rhodia moi mais tu fais des
t-shirts des deux thoniers c'est bon que
des marques me prête parce qu'elles sont
réveillés on au prato rien à cirer que
non mais là là c'est réussi
mais quoi excusez moi je connais pas
d'émission du gotha et surtout pas la
vie a échoué à saluer de buffet c'est
assez méchant alors vous dites qu'il
échoue et n'ont jamais oublié qu'ils en
ont marre s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
finir un oui je vous le dis à dieu
vous avez fait ça on peut pas vous
l'enlever vous avez fait ou
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous rêvez vous avez fait ou fait
d'ailleurs regardez
[Applaudissements]
et oui ou sur nrj 12 la finale avait
rassemblé 205000 theater non 205
téléspectateurs de la prod
bonsoir à tout
c'est l'événement ce soir sur nrj 12
c'est la grande première de wouf
allez hop pas bougé pas bougé walt pas
bougé pas bougé malgré elle
j'espère que j'ai passé un très bon
temps avec tes nouveaux amis les chiens
coulisses et côté pas trop manqué alors
pas du tout pour le tout mais alors pas
si vous avez acheté les images qu'elle a
rompu en août les bras alors oui je vais
vous dire ça maintenant un petit billet
cette affaire les gars merci oui parce
que c'est vous qui avez produit non je
n'ai pas eu ce bonheur
non non non non j'ai juste animée
c'était qui produisait
[Rires]
c'est comme ça